ربما لا يعكر صفو هذه الانطلاقه الطائره
الا مزاج المغاربه هذه الايام
مزاج تتحكم فيه انتصارات فريق لكره القدم
اصبح يلعب في حلبه الكبار وحلم يراودهم ان
يحلق الحارس ياسين بونو ورفاقه عاليا في
سماء المونديال القطري
للناس
ان شاء الله باذن الله
يمكن تقول الناس
يا سيدي ان شاء الله
فرنسا ومنتخبنا اذا يقفان الان امام تحقيق
حلم المغاربه الاسماء والمشروع وهو الوصول
الى المباراه النهائيه وتحقيق الكاس
العالميه واهداؤها كمثل يحتذى به لاجيال
القادمه
يقول والكاتب الاورغواياني الراحل ادواردو
غاليانو الذي حاول تقديم تفسير عقلاني
لشغف الناس بكره القدم يقول ان المشاعر
التي تنتاب المراه خلال مباراه كره القدم
هي عباره عن اختزال لما قد ينتبه ديله
حياه كامله لان اللعبه في نظره ما هي الا
مراه تعكس واقع الحياه
للاحتفال بجزئه المضيء عندما سيخرجون
الاستقبال اسود الاطلس بعد عودتهم من قطر
سواء عادوا بالكاس او بدونها فالاكيد ان
ما حققوه في هذا المونديال سيبقى محفورا
في ذاكرته المغاربه والافارقه والعرب وفي
وجداني كل عاشق لنشوه الساحره المستديره
عبد المنعم العمراني الجزيره الرباط